first of all let me say this is one of
my favorite shows on any channel I love
it so much it's a pleasure to be able to
talk to you guys today so I want to
start I've seen the first three episodes
of season 2 and I want to start with my
grievance right up front I strongly
object to the season being nine episodes
I need it to be 56 so what do we need to
do to make future seasons much longer
than eight or nine episodes I think you
just got a clone these two happily 50
said yeah you have to this is not like a
[ __ ] thing with me I need more you
know I mean um but when being serious
when did you guys know after season 1
that you were gonna come back for
another season how early did you kind of
get that England we knew it during the
season one that we were going for a
second season
I remember at Christmastime we hunted
like I said yeah but I think it's it
really a credit to David that there is
the tendency when your show is a success
to go immediately make a second season
and give everybody kind of the greatest
hits and turn it out because it's good
business to do that but he was very even
though we had an early pickup we were
just finishing wrapping it and we found
out you know we were gonna go again he
really waited until he felt like all the
scripts were right so as fun as it would
be to to the 56 I think the reason that
it's good is because he really takes his
time and thinks about it so much and
really make sure that it's putting
something that he really believes in out
there instead of just like turning it
out no completely and by the way I know
that's the reason it's yeah yeah of
course yeah it takes time to be awesome
you know you got you got to do it right
um but one of the things that I really
enjoyed about without getting into
spoilers of season 2 is that it seems
like the characters are taking home with
them what's happening on the job like
they're they're feeling the emotional
impact or am i mistaking this a little
bit no I think that they absolutely are
I think it's sort of that's a little bit
at the thing that runs through is that
you know the whole the whole season
starts with that awesome you know shot
of the mask I won't give anything away
for people watched it and I think that
that's a little bit
so you know we sort of start to see what
mosques we're all wearing what patterns
of behavior we are unaware of in
ourselves how that in you know infects
an effect so our personal life and what
kind of toll that takes on everybody one
of the things that's amazing is you guys
have three amazing directors in season
two each of which have I would imagine
their own talent their own way of
working could you talk a little bit
about working with Carl Andrew and David
and maybe the differences that they
bring on set well you know David is of
course a very meticulous and really
strives for to make things as good as
they can possibly be
and so to Andrew and and Carl but in a
different way um David would will do
more setups will do more takes in each
set up and likes to set a scene in
rehearsal and then once the scene is set
likes to see the actor continued to do
basically what we've said in rehearsal
with small adjustments that he will give
you between takes um Andrew can be a
little bit more improvisational and you
know and Carl is is is is is a director
that just kind of flows and when he sees
something that he likes and he feels
like he has it moves so um they have
three very different styles but they're
they're all very exciting to work with
for different reasons before the season
began how many of the nine scripts did
you actually have we had all of them you
know however you know we we do continue
to refine them as the as the season goes
on um but yeah we we we knew what the
arc of the story was before we ever set
out I mean I think that one of the big
mistakes that some television television
producers make is you know not knowing
where the the destination of the journey
when when they start out you know and if
we're very fortunate in the sense that
the reason we took so long but
in season one and season two is because
David and the writers really wanted
tremendous clarity about what the
personal journeys of each of these
characters was going to be over the
course of the season right it seems like
there's a lot of scenes on airplanes of
you guys flying
are you filming a lot of those scenes on
the same days or is there just one set
that's being redressed with different
seatback you know there's what we have
like a plane on on one of those stages
that they would use but I was gonna ask
you guys this cuz I did a thing on it
one thing I like falling asleep and I
was like then I was like nodding often
like I don't know what I'm doing like
like literally on my side like when the
camera is on me and then I could often
they like going oh yeah that's the it
didn't happen to me but I know what
you're talking about this [ __ ] that the
perfect girl oh wait so are you filming
a lot of that stuff at the same time or
is it just a set that's on a soundstage
and when you need it you just go back it
is a set that's on a on a soundstage and
we use it at different times in the
season but sometimes if there is a day
where we have you know if there's an
episode where we have more than one
plane scene then yes we'll combine them
sure um
what listen it was talked before the
first season came out that David was
talking about this being like a five
year plan or a five season we're hopeful
right I wanted to know is that still the
thing where it's a five season plan
we've we want it to be yeah you know I
mean that's what that's what David's
intention in the beginning and I know
that you know it's been a very rewarding
experience for all of us making the show
audiences seem to really love the show
there seems to be a tremendous amount of
excitement and anticipation for the next
season and yeah I mean we would I
personally would love to do season three
four and five
looking back on season one well actually
want to ask you about season two is
there was there talked a little about
the challenges of the season and maybe
what was the stuff that since you had
all nine scripts that you were really
excited to do and maybe something that
you saw in the script you're like oh
this is going to be a really really
awful day on set mm well speaking to the
mothers and the of the event of the
Atlanta child murders was pretty
heartbreaking that the scene which
you've seen right the video that Anna
said earlier your this season really
getting to see the victims side of the
story in a way that you didn't maybe
necessarily in the first season and so
that was really intense and and I didn't
in the first season everyone would
always ask us what was you know did you
do you is it's hard to go to sleep at
night or do you demons of the and I
never had anything like that but I do
remember on the day with the mothers
when they were talking about and they
were crying and as these amazing
actresses that was the most sort of that
was the day that stuck with me the most
for sure for you guys a couple of things
that come later I think for me it's
definitely the tension that's created in
Bill's life because he's kind of being
pulled in two different directions well
that's what I was gonna say manager okay
um between my responsibilities as a
husband and a father and and also my
professional responsibilities as as an
FBI agent
you know investigating the Atlanta child
murders with my with my partner that was
also a beaut I think I fit in the first
that was a beautiful scene when you meet
with the victim live victim in the back
of the car - right I remember that was
like that was pretty harrowing to watch
yeah the only survivor of an attack by
BTK Dennis Rader bind torture kill would
you trust strangler you know that's a
it's a very powerful scene but there are
a lot of powerful scenes in season two
it's a great season we're really proud
of it I gotta go I want to I sincerely
say again one of the best things on TV
thank you so much for making it
entertaining all of us